Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in Alwaji in the book of purification
regarding the rulings of Alif.
So menration and postpartum
the author after having introduced
and introduced the rulings of each he
goes into
the two the things which are
impermissible
for a woman who is currently in a state
of ministration
or postpartum and
now we mentioned yesterday that al
doesn't have any maximum or minimum
amount of time. It could be very long.
It could be very short. It's different
with different women. However, a nephes
which is postpartum bleeding. This has
no minimum. So it could be a day, could
be two days, but it does have a maximum
and the maximum is 40 days. At 40 days,
she is no longer in a state of
postpartum. Even if the blood continues
past 40 days, this may be a medical
issue. This may be you know known
culturally as postpartum or you know
aden but in the legislation of Islam it
doesn't recognize it past 40 days. At 40
days 41 days she is no longer in a state
of postpartum. She is now in the ruling
of
and we'll discuss this inshallah when we
get there. He says what is the things
which are impermissible
for a woman in a state of ministration
or postpartum. What is impermissible for
her to do?
The author takes a very strange turn
here
because
he doesn't mention
one thing that we added back at the
beginning when we were discussing what
is haram for a person in a state of
hadith to do. Remember a person who does
not have wudoo what is haram for him to
do we mentioned how many things three
things right we said salah
and the Quran handling the Quran he
didn't mention the third one right and
here he doesn't mention that either
because he builds on that he says
[Arabic recitation]
a state of hadith, minor hadith, what we
just discussed, those three things,
is haram for a woman who is in a state
of
with an addition of two things. Number
one, fasting. Number two, inter
intercourse.
Fasting and intercourse.
Those two become an addition to those
two things he mentioned earlier. We
mention them as three. So it becomes
five things that is not permissible for
a woman in a state of ministration or
postpartum to do. He says as for fasting
she is merely to skip those days and
then make them up later. Make them up
when she is clear of her or
[Silence]
of
for
[Silence]
the Muslim. So then he mentions the
various evidences from the Quran and
Sunnah
regarding the prohibition of a woman in
a state of
h
menration and fast postpartum.
It is impermissible
for her to pray and fast
and make dwa
and handle the mus
and finally
you know intercourse. Now what if a
woman were to handle the mus that's like
a book of we mentioned this before
right? That's not the musaf,
right? Musaf is what is mostly Quran
or if she were to handle the English
translation, this doesn't apply either.
This is not considered the Quran in that
sense. or for instance
if she were to have
gloves on
when she handles the musf. Many scholars
view this also as being permissible if
it is the musf. But they all agree that
reading the musaf, reading the Quran off
of an electronic device,
let's say an iPad or a computer or a
telephone,
that you do not have to have for that.
And a woman may do that when she is in a
state of menration or postpartum. So
there's many options. The only thing
which is impermissible is handling the
physical mus that is mostly Quran.
that is the only thing which is
impermissible for her and for a person
who is not have woo.
foreign.
[Silence]
I don't know what to do. victim.